hey you were in the car what's it like I
was in the car and it is super fast I
was actually in the one that they call
the ludicrous mode which goes super
super fast okay so just to give you some
there I am okay just to give you some
background David look this has gone
through several delays right this this
this Model X SUV but it comes with some
really cool features the Falcon wing
doors the 17 audio speakers to deliver
that premium quality and you can't
really tell in this video but there's a
it's a panoramic windshield Elon Musk
says it's the the largest piece of glass
ever made for any vehicle ever and it it
makes you you know what the best scene
in the house actually in that car is in
the second row seat because you're
almost feel like you're you know you're
driving a convertible except that you
don't have all that wind in your hair so
it is really really really cool and as
you mentioned the price tag actually for
the one that I drove the ludicrous mode
it's a hundred and forty two thousand
dollars for that that's slightly more or
actually significantly more than the
Model S which is at around ninety three
thousand dollars comparable features
that sort of thing so David it is a it
is a very cool car and it is certainly
the you know it is the third model to
come out from Tesla and certainly the
foundation of the building block when
the last ones before Elon Musk builds a
mass-market model 3 let me ask you about
that just in second first I know it has
this panoramic window these Falcon door
is this what if this bio defense button
what does it do okay so what do you love
was saying was that because their air
filtration system is so state-of-the-art
that if if god forbid something were to
happen and you needed to get to a safe
place you could literally go into your
car and hit the bio defense button and
you would be safer in your car than any
other bunker there you go
that's his way of injecting a little
humor into it let me ask you lastly you
mentioned that model 3 this is a vehicle
to be less than $35,000 in electric
vehicle less than $35,000 is he on track
is Tesla on
tract to get that on the market here he
says he is this Model X was delayed
several times but the but but the model
likes they learned quite a bit from
building it from tooling around with it
so it was one of the last key critical
blocks you could say or stumbling blocks
before they get to the model three which
is going to be delivered in the next few
years
alright Bloomberg's Betty Lou with the
amiable experience of getting to drive
the new the new Tesla Model X joining us
from San Francisco